after booking up on london and playing
it exclusively for a while and getting a
bit bored
what okay would you recommend a london
fan to study
a london fan to study
oh i mean i'm immediately thinking of
like system-based openings
so maybe i i can recommend the bufferic
english
i showed this other day on stream i
don't know if
like the leachat's opening book will
will recognize like the name
but in general uh just to draw some
arrows
the setup is knight c3 g3 bishop g2
e4 knight ge2
d3 castling and then later f4 and then
later you you attack on
the king's side so
imagine black does nothing this is
usually the order in which you play
now we should assume that black will do
something
um yeah usually you do this and then
i mean we could keep going
king usually likes to go to h2 i'm
covering the pawn
i'll give one more example this time
black will actually do something
let's say black plays e5 and just like a
standard
what should we call it four knights
let's say g6
uh you still go for e4 like g6 here
knight f6 here
it's one dollar oh neil heat
loved the video with lele i appreciate
that
yeah that video was posted earlier today
newest video on youtube yeah if you're
just joining um i
started the stream playing a tournament
now i'm playing viewers and trying to
answer
questions and provide some value
showing oh leachat has a long name for
this
english opening kings in king's english
variation english to qgd transposition
botanic was playing a lot i kind of like
it
you'll try it out thanks yeah
maybe maybe i'll try it in one of my
next games too what if black copycats
possible if black copycats then i mean
usually
if you're white you're going to have a
small advantage if it's a symmetrical
position
and you have an extra tempo
so in general it's nothing to be too
scared of
uh just to show maybe some ideas here
like let's say black plays bishop e6
you don't want to play bishop e3 if
black can play knight g4 hitting your
bishop
so this is a case where you play h3
first
preventing knight chief or preparing
bishop e3
if black creates the battery to attack
the pawn
you can safely play king h2
this is a very typical mechanism and
then the pawn's always defended
you're still going for this and
eventually f4
hey at least three chicken
nuggets sub tier one for three months in
advance
thanks so much oh
do i do it i should do it
i always do it when people sub in
advance
alexa what date will it be three months
from now
three months from now will be march 2021
march wait not march 1st though
alexa what date will it be three months
from now
three months from now will be march 2021
that's so ambiguous it'll be pi day
oh it'll be pi day alexa
remind me on pi day to thank at least
three chicken mcnuggets
or no just chicken nuggets what time
friday should i remind you
no pie day not friday remind me at noon
okay i'll remind you friday at noon
no
ah i guess i'll be reminded earlier
that's okay though oh this is like um
this has been reached before so i was
gonna say
the reason why you play knight e2 is to
prepare f4
and that's why you don't play knight f3
because you want to accelerate the the
pawn storm
oh i'm white let me deactivate
emote only for now and we're going to do
we're going to do the english opening
that i was showing earlier
it's a so-called botvinnik system
could start with knight c3 or g3 don't
think it makes a huge difference
oh
so with c6 black wants to play d5 i'm
gonna play e4 here
preventing d5
okay now g3
oh rmt with silent bits
you have to say alexis simon says
whatever you want
alexa simon says whatever you want
english time whatever you want
oh wait what oh
what openings did you mainly use for the
one crore 20 lakh 1600 part of your
chess career
journey
hello hello
1200 oh um so when i was at rating range
i had a coach who who kind of
hand fed me openings
um i played e4 as white
i played open sicilian everything
classical variation
i played the tarash against the french
i kind of played i played the roy lopez
exchange variation
for a period of time but then i also
played the molar attack
uh play h3 first
just covering g4
um as black i was playing queen's game
declined
and then e4 e5 as black
so i hope that answers your question
i did not develop the chrome extension
for the the random challenge that was
that was uh do you ever do the magic of
stock
tactics or just study from books
oh opponent wants to to hurt me
so h4 can be met with g4 so i'm not
really too scared
i'll continue following the
the setup i was showing earlier
yeah lecha's tactics are are very nice
um
[Music]
yeah you'll you'll learn from both
i'll play bishop e3 now
books are books can still offer more
benefit
because a lot of books will offer
kind of themed tactics more explanations
but if you just want to solve the chess
tactics are great catch you on the pawn
side
oh catch me on the pawn oh the pawn side
well in chess there's a king side in the
queen side
but the pawn side okay let's start
throwing pawns
so we've yeah we're entering a position
where now
i have to react to what black is doing
and with the king on the
queen side i just want to attack
i'm probably going for b5 it's all about
opening files
if the b or c file open it'll be really
really nice
why not take the pawn on g5 because i'm
blind
but also like black wants to open the
file
on the king's side so i'd i'd rather
just not mess with anything
and keep the focus on the queen side
this is a classic situation where
it's pretty much impossible for black to
break through with just these pawns
if g4 i play h4 if h4 i play g4
and if the king side stays closed
there is no attack and i can focus on
the queen's side
hello good luck from monaco hey it's
monaco
alexa what time is it in monaco
it's 8 54 p.m oh good evening
and cheswee what's up chest weeb shout
out to the weeb
i'm beating g spates this time g spates
added an extra s
and blaze yes first time watching not on
youtube
welcome to twitch oh this move
gives me so much joy
i could play a7 and win material
i could also i think i want to start
with knight b5
and then we'll see what black does
yeah there's some fun opportunities here
so i'm attacking the queen that's a move
but now i play this move
wait let's play this move
oh xy sparks is asking a valid question
h4 g4 in black could sack
now it doesn't really matter because too
much is happening on the
queen side um
yeah that's a fair point black could
sack and get initiative
but uh the files would still be closed
for black because of the pawns would
remain here
so the rooks can't really be so useful
in attacking like the king
at least in some variations
oh wow i don't think i can resist
i can't resist
i have three nights i have three nights
the queen's attacked by two of my
knights
and this is meat yeah oh it's too
beautiful
and not every day you get to
have mate on the board before move 20
with three nights objectively it wasn't
the best move
a black could take this night then i
only have two nights
but uh that worked out nicely
or should i say nicely
it was a fun game thanks to my opponent
ruzilla playing an interesting setup
it's probably going on youtube
english leads to i don't know what i'll
call it
i'll brainstorm some titles yeah hello
to youtube
we had one person at least one person
watching for the first time on twitch
but little did they know
they were watching a future youtube
video
it was a nice um basically got
everything i wanted from the opening
it's especially nice and blitz like if
black's not challenging you in any clear
way you can
usually play the first 10 moves
but can you choose a blunder hello
youtube and doggy
double question mark
oh it wants me to play knight a4 and get
the bishop hair
oh stockfish is a little harsh with that
bishop oh i could have yeah i should
have taken a g5
i was i was so blind
i'm saying hello to my future self
watching youtube
yeah hello to future raco games
but the hello only works if you watch
the video again on youtube and then you
have to respond to your hello in the
comments
hi to my future kids oh wait
oh yeah hello to grandmaster gary's
grandchildren
alexa remind me in
10 years to give
team uh
give some tea to grandmaster gary's
grandchildren
wait no 10 years is too short
14 20 30 should i remind you oh yeah
um just say hi to gary check in see how
he's doing
what time december 14th oh what time 30
should i remind you
um i don't know what my sleep schedule
will be like
1 pm
how long for how long what do you mean
30 minutes sorry i'm not sure i'm not
sure either
i don't know if it's gonna remind me
i'll just have to remember